Roxie's on inside our cell is considered
to be a recycle center of the cell now
if we imagine cell to be a big Factory
then the recycling hub is the peroxisome
and there are key aspects of recycling
taking place in the peroxisome most
notably the fatty acid oxidation
especially the long-chain fatty acid and
branch fatty acids D amino acids and
even sometimes of poly amines are
getting oxidized in the peroxisome
and the whole plethora of tasks that
these paroxysm takes place is done by
the enzymes inside the peroxisomes and
peroxisome has a huge variety of oxidase
enzymes
it also has catalase now oxidase can
attach or oxidize a group and create
hydrogen peroxide now catalase our other
set of enzymes which can degrade
hydrogen peroxide because hydrogen
peroxide is harmful for the cell it's a
reactive oxygen species to water and
oxygen so catalase oxidase and many
other like peroxisomal proteins need to
be delivered to the peroxisome paroxysm
don't have their own protein production
machinery like mitochondria so all the
genes that are actually coding for the
peroxisomal enzymes and nuclear genes so
definitely the peroxisomal enzymes are
transcribed in the nucleus and then they
are translated into the ER so
peroxisomal enzymes are transcribed into
the nucleus translated into the ER and
from there they are going to be
delivered to the paroxysm so this video
is all about how this delivery mechanism
works so one question we should first
ask that how peroxisomal enzymes are
selectively delivered to peroxisome not
to any other places and the answer is
quite simple just like we have seen in
case of mitochondria there is a
mitochondrial
localization signal which would drive
the transport of the protein to
mitochondria and not anyplace else
peroxisome distant proteins also have
the peroxisomal translocation signal or
pts most of the cases it has a pts one
signal which is basically serine leucine
and said in lysine and reducing but some
of the cases-- they also have a pts 2
signal which is very uncommon now the
mitochondrial protein transport is a bit
different from peroxisomal protein
transport because in mitochondria the
proteins that need to be transported
need to be bound to chaperones and
maintained in an unfolded state and then
delivered to the mitochondria in
comparison to that peroxisomal proteins
let's say catalase which is an important
proximal protein can be transported to
peroxisome in its native situation even
the cofactors it's attached so the heme
group of the peroxisomal catalase is
that attached while it is transported
now how do you know that this particular
sequence that is driving the protein
into mitochondria or peroxisome is
necessary and sufficient for this
delivery mechanism so let's say you have
a protein which is actually having a
mitochondrial localization signal so
since it has a mitochondrial
localization signal it would normally be
delivered to mitochondria but let's say
you do a thought experiment where you
cleave the signal and put a lysosome at
put a peroxisomal translocation signal
into that then what would happen
scientists have observed in with
experiments that this protein is now
delivered to paroxysm instead of
mitochondria so these signals are super
important more specific in in
experiments have shown that when
scientists use the cytosolic GFP which
is normally present in the cytosol and
it would glow like this under a
fluorescence microscope now when they
take the cytosolic GFP and attach a
proximal translocation signal to it
instead of staying in the cytosol
cytosolic gfp is now transported to the
peroxisome cell now you can see speckles
inside the cells which are like GFP
positive so basically now the peroxisome
cell highlighted in gfp that means the
cytosolic gfp has been now transported
to the peroxisomes so that tells us this
particular C terminal sequence or
peroxisome target sequence is efficient
to transport the paroxysm protein to the
peroxisomes now let's just talk about
this process in a bit more detail so
here is our protein of interest let's
say oxidase enzyme that need to be
transported into the paroxysm and on the
surface of the paroxysm there would be
pics family of translocon now point to
be noted that these paroxysm the protein
that need to be delivered to the
paroxysm should have the proximal target
sequence
now this proximal target sequence can
bind to paroxysm proximal target
sequence receptor or pts are normally it
is also known as X 5 so what would
happen is that these the the overall the
basics of it is like this PT SR would
take it to the pix family translocon and
it would interact with pix family
translocon and allow the protein to be
channeled inside the peroxisome but this
process is bit difficult and let's just
talk about it in a little bit more
detail say so the translocon complex the
pics translocon complex is actually made
up of four components X 2 X 10 which is
a main translocon channel
X 12 and pix 14 so basically the pts are
or the pics 5 points to pix 14 along
with the protein that need to be
translocated inside the inside the
peroxisome now the whole pix 14 and pics
5 complex along with the protein that
need to be translocated mobilize get
mobilized to the translocon channel
complex then the protein with the pts
sequence gets into the pics 10
translocon channel and the
PTS are our picks five gets dissociated
and it can be used for another cycle of
protein from protein targeting to the X
14 and that is how the protein which is
important for peroxisomal normal
physiology gets inside the paroxysm now
you these translocon channels are not
proper there could be several mutations
in the translocon channel it has been
seen that there are multiple genetic
disorders of these translocon channel
give rise to severe problems in terms of
physiology so these protein
translocation into the peroxisome is
also very important process I hope you
enjoyed this video if you liked this
video give it a thumbs up don't forget
to Like share and subscribe